this is true a retired man recently
noticed that someone has been tidying up
his shed during the night his work shed
he had no idea who it was
so he put a security camera in the shed
and he found out it was a mouse it was a
mouse that was cleaning up this is a
hundred percent true real story yes
every night the mouse would clean up
loose screws and other items that the
man left out and neatly file them away
in a toolbox here's the footage that the
guy released it's so sweet take a look
there's the mouse I was just putting
things away and he would do this every
night it is the sweetest thing in the
world yeah I thought that was really
lovely and that was just one of those
little sweet stories that you see and
you think well that's nice let's talk
about that
and I noticed that apparently it's that
wasn't the only place that the mouse
tried to help out the man place cameras
all around his home and some of the
footage he is if you thought that was
great
truly astounding take a look at this
there's the mouse getting the man's
morning coffee ready he would do that he
would get his coffee ready yes yeah
there's the mouse giving the man a
pedicure while he's asleep and he would
do that at night while he's sleeping
here he is talking the man stopped
top the guys tub foreign he would do his
laundry while the man was sleeping - he
would alphabetize his vinyl collection
yeah and just make sure that it was
everything the writer wallpapering the
kitchen the mouse wood wallpaper the
kitchen and he would do the man's taxes
I thought that was really nice
oh there he is helping to redact Imola
reports
what a lovely mouth